[SQUEAKING][RUSTLING][CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: So we are--
welcome back, everybody.
And we are going to
continue our discussion
of computability theory,
Turing machines, and how
to prove things undecidable,
which is what we've been doing.
So we talked about this
more advanced method
of proving things undecidable
last lecture, called
the computation history
method, which comes up
in all sorts of proofs of
undecidability, usually more
complex ones.
Such as, for example, the
proof of Hilbert's 10th problem
that I mentioned,
whether you want
to-- if you want to test
whether a polynomial has
a solution in integers.
It's a reduction from
ATM, just like we've
been doing all along.
All of those proofs are
pretty much reductional
from something undecidable.
This reduction from ATM is as
good a starting point as any.
And it uses the
computation history method.
So what they end up doing
is, given a Turing machine
and an input, you
construct a polynomial
that has several variables.
And where in order to
get an integer root,
an integer solution
of that polynomial,
one of the variables
is going to have
to be assigned to
some kind of encoding
of a computation history of
the Turing machine of M on w.
One of those variables is going
to be a computation history--
an integer which represents the
computation history for m on W.
And the other
variables are there
to help you kind
of decode that so
that the polynomial can actually
check and make a solution.
It becomes a solution
if that actually
is a legitimate computation
history of m on W.
So it really uses the very
same method that we've
been using all along,
but it's pretty hairy
to construct that polynomial
and do the check in the way
that you need to do.
So for the Post
Correspondence problem
which we introduced last
time, doing the check
is relatively simple.
You know that the match is
the computation history,
and following the
rules of the match,
it's fairly simple to construct
that Post Correspondence
problem instance.
We talked about linearly
bounded automata.
Of course, we defined
configurations and computation
histories along the way and
proved certain problem--
other problems are undecidable
as well using the same method.
OK, so today, we're
going to shift gears.
We're going to--
in our last lecture
on the computability
section of the course,
we're going to talk about
something called the recursion
theorem, which basically gives
Turing machines the ability
to refer to themselves.
Turing machines in
any program, to do
self-reference so
that you can actually
get at the code of
the Turing machine
or the code of the program
that you're writing.
Even if that's not a built-in
primitive of the programming
language or the operating
system that you're working with,
it still gives you that access.
And also, we're going to--
if we have time at the end,
I'm going to talk a little bit
about mathematical logic, which
is sort of a nice application
of the recursion theorem.
And it's a beautiful
subject on its own.
And it's something that I can
give a brief introduction to.
OK, so today's topic is
about self-reference,
self-reproducing machines,
and the broader topic
called the recursion theorem.
So let me introduce it
with what I would call
the self-reproduction paradox.
And that is, suppose you have
a factory, like a Tesla effect
or a car manufacturing factory.
See, there's a picture
of the factory,
and it's producing cars.
All right?
So we have a factory
that makes cars.
And what can we say about the
relative complexity of the cars
compared with the factory,
in some informal sense?
So I would argue
that you would be
reasonable to say that the
complexity of the factory
is going to have to be greater
than the complexity of the cars
that it makes.
Because not only
does the factory
have to know how
to make the cars,
so it has to have
all the instructions
and whatever things
that go into a car,
it has to be included in
at least some kind of--
it has to be, in some sense,
represented in the factory.
But the factory also has
to have other stuff--
the robots, and the other
manufacturing items,
tools, and so on--
for making the cars.
So the factory has to
have all the complexity
of a car incorporated
plus other things as well.
And for that reason,
one could imagine
that the factory's complexity is
more than the car's complexity.
But now, suppose you want
to have a factory that
makes factories--
so imagine here's the picture--
or in general, a machine
that makes copies of itself.
Well, that seems, at first
glance, to be impossible.
Because not only does
the factory obviously
have to have all of the
instructions for what
a factory is like, but it needs
to have all of the extra things
that it would need to
do the manufacturing.
And so for that reason,
it seems like it's not
possible to have a machine
make copies of itself.
I mean, you would run
into the very same problem
if I asked you to
produce a program
in your favorite language
that prints out itself--
an exact copy of the same code.
You can always write
a program which
is going to print out some
string, like Hello, world.
That's easy because you
just put Hello, world
into some kind of a variable
or some sort of a table
into the program and
say print that table.
But if you want the program
to print out a copy of itself,
you can't take the whole program
and stick that into a table
because the program
is going to have
to be bigger than the table.
And so, you're going to
end up with something
impossible happening.
Because the program-- an
entire copy of the program
can't fit inside the program.
You just get the program
inside itself, inside itself,
inside itself, forever.
And so, you end up with an
infinite program that way.
So if you just kind of
naively approach the problem
for how to make a
program which is
going to print out a copy of
itself, it's not so easy to do.
But hopefully, after
today's lecture,
you will see that it is possible
and in fact, how to do it.
And not only that is an
idle bit of curiosity,
but there are
actually applications
for why you might want
to do that, mainly
within mathematics and in
computer science theory.
But there's even a kind of
a real-world application,
if you will, in a way too.
So we'll get to that at the end.
So it seems, as I'm
saying, impossible to have
a self-reproducing machine.
But we know that
in the world, there
are things that make copies
of themselves-- living things.
So it seems like a paradox.
Cells can make copies
exactly of themselves.
All living things can
make copies of themselves.
So how do they manage to
get around this paradox?
Well, in fact, it is no
paradox because it is possible
to make a machine
that self-reproduces,
that makes copies of itself.
And this has been
known for many years.
Probably, it goes
back to Von Neumann
who wrote a famous paper on
self-reproducing machines.
OK, so self-reproducing
machines are, in fact, possible.
So let me give you
an example of how
you would make a
self-reproducing Turing
machine.
What do we mean by that?
I mean a machine--
I'm going to call it SELF--
which ignores its input.
So on any input, you turn it
on, the machine grinds around
for a while, and halts with
a description of itself
on the tape--
with the description
of SELF, its own code,
sitting on the tape.
So very much like
producing a program which
would print out its own code,
that's really what we're doing.
So for that, we're
going to first need
a little lemma, which
is a very simple lemma,
but it looks worse than it is.
So let me just
read it out to you,
and then I'll explain
what its saying.
Because what it's saying
is extremely simple.
So there's a
computable function,
I'm going to call
it q, that maps
strings to strings, which
will take any string,
w, and produce from w a Turing
machine which will print w.
OK?
That's all it does.
So as you know, if I
give you a string, w,
you could produce
a Turing machine
which would have w
represented in the states
and transitions of the machine.
So that if you turn the machine
on, the machine will output w.
If I want you to give
me a Turing machine that
prints the string 1, 1, 0, 1 on
the tape, you could do that--
I hope.
And no matter what that
string was, instead of 1, 1,
0, 0, or whatever, it's
20 0's and then five 1's,
you could do that too.
And in fact, there's
a simple procedure
that takes a string
and maps that
onto a Turing machine which
prints out that string.
So that's a computable function,
which basically takes a string
and converts it to something
that evaluates to that string.
And I'm calling it q.
I don't know if this is
helpful to you or not.
It's kind of like it converts
the string w to w in quotes.
So q stands for
quotes, in a way.
So if that's helpful, then good.
But anyway, Pw is
a Turing machine.
When you turn it on, it
just prints out w and halts.
And I can find Pw from w--
straightforward proof.
So now, I'm going to
tell you, assuming
that we have that
computable function, q,
I'm going to tell you how
to make this machine SELF.
And it's not complicated.
The Turing machine
SELF is going to have
two parts I'll call
A and B. Here's
a schematic for the machine.
So here's SELF.
It's in two parts A and B.
And what I mean by A and B,
it's like two separate teams.
SELF is going to
start out running A,
and when A is finished, it's
going to pass control to B.
And then B is going
to finish the job.
And when it's done, you're
going to have the description
SELF sitting here on the tape.
All right?
So what's left is to give
you the code for A and for B.
So A is going to be
something super simple.
A is going to be that
machine which prints out B--
prints out a description
of B. The one
that I described up here.
So remember, Pw is the
machine which prints out w.
And P sub the description
of B is simply
going to machine that has
this string, PB, stored
in its states and transitions.
You turn on that machine,
and it prints out B,
and then it's done.
So this is a very simple--
A is very simple.
So here, PB is a part of
A. And when it's done,
B appears on the tape.
So that's at the point when
A has finished its work.
Now it's going to
pass control to B.
So we're not obviously done
yet, because what we want
is A and B both
to be on the tape,
not just B. Because SELF
is a combination of A and B
together.
So I have to tell you how
B works to finish the job.
So you might think,
as a first, given
what we did for
getting B on the tape,
that we'll get A on the
tape in the same way,
by putting a copy of A inside
B. So a copy of B is inside A,
and a copy of A is inside B.
And at some
conceptual level, that
seems like that
might do the job.
But it's really not--
that is not a solution.
Because the fact that I
can put B inside A kind of
forbids me from also
putting A inside
P, because that's going
to be the same kind
of circular reasoning
of just putting
a machine inside itself.
You just can't do
that because you're
going to end up with an
infinitely big machine
that way.
In fact, if I'm
putting B inside A--
a copy of B in terms of
its description inside A, A
is really going to be
much bigger than B.
Because it has all of B with
inside it, plus other stuff--
all the states and transitions
for printing that B out.
So I can't have the A
be much bigger than B
and then B also
much bigger than A.
So this is no good.
We're going to have
to do something else.
So how is B now going
to get ahold of A?
And the trick for doing
that, without having
a copy of A inside B--
which doesn't work.
That's not going to
be a good solution.
Instead, the way that
B is going to get A,
it's going to figure
out what A is.
It's going to figure
And how is it going to
figure out what A is?
Because if you remember, B can
now look can look at the tape.
It sees some string
there which happens
to be a description of
itself, but it doesn't care.
It sees some string on the tape.
A is the machine that
prints out that string.
A is q of this string.
So B is simply going to
compute q of whatever it
sees on the tape.
That is A. OK?
So I don't know if you can read.
That's kind of small here.
It's going to compute A
from B sitting on the tape.
So here is the
instructions for B.
It's going to compute q of
the tape contents, which
happens to be the
description of B.
But that's irrelevant
to B. B just sees
some string on the tape.
It computes q of
that, and that is A.
Because A is the machine
which prints out that string.
Then it's going to
combine A with B,
doing whatever
slight interfacing
that needs to happen--
I'm not going to get
into those details--
to convert those two
pieces into one machine,
which is the machine SELF.
And then it's going to print out
with SELF on the tape, as I'm
going to indicate over here.
OK?
So that's how a
Turing machine can
print out a copy of
its own description
and leave it on the tape.
And what's nice
about this is nothing
specific about Turing machines.
This is a general
procedure that allows
any programming
language to print out
a copy of its own code.
You can even carry
this out in English,
as I'm going to do
in the next slide.
OK, so here's a good question.
There are many possible
Turing machines that
can print out B. That's right.
How do I know how to
get the particular one?
What I have in mind,
that's a little bit
of a subtle question,
but it's a good question.
I have in mind the
particular Turing machine
that prints out B, which
is the one that q produces.
Remember, so we have to
refer back to this lemma.
This lemma produces
a particular machine
that prints out B from B.
And that's the one that
I'm going to use for A,
and that's the one
that B is going
to be able to obtain by running
the q algorithm to figure out
what A is.
So you have to make sure
you're being consistent then.
That's a little bit of a detail,
but it's a good question.
And why doesn't this create
a circular argument too?
Well, so that was
another question
I'm seeing here on the tape.
Well, there's no
longer anything-- see,
B does not have to have
A stored within it.
It figures out A.
So in a sense, you're going
to write the code for B first.
B is just a simple program.
Here it is.
There's nothing
circular about it.
It says B is a
simple-- the code for B
is, take a look at the
tape, compute q of that,
combine the result with
whatever was sitting on the tape
from before, and print it out.
I mean, that's a piece of
code which you can just write.
This will become more
clear, hopefully,
in our next slide
where we talk about
the English implementation.
But just, I don't
want to rush to that.
So you could figure out B
without even knowing what A is.
B stands alone.
But then, because B is
just a piece of code
that runs q based on
what it sees on the tape.
A, now you need to
know what B is in order
to obtain A. Because A has
the code for B embedded
within A as a string.
So first you produce B, then
you can figure out-- then
you can obtain A.
There's nothing
circular in this argument.
I don't know if
that's helpful to you,
but you may need
to mull it over.
Or maybe it'll be helpful
from the next slide.
So let's go there now.
So as I'm saying, you can
implement this in any language.
In particular, you can
implement it in English.
So let's just shift gears.
Let's talk about writing
down English instructions.
And then I'll show what
happens if you carry out
those instructions.
So let's start simple.
How about the sentence,
Write "Hello World."
So an obedient person
reading those instructions
would then write "Hello World"
on their paper or wherever.
OK, fine, hopefully
you get the idea.
So now, what I'd like--
here's another sentence,
another instruction.
Write this sentence.
And the obedient reader would
then, OK, Write this sentence.
This is the kind of
thing I'm looking for.
Here is a sentence which
instructs the reader
to make an exact copy.
But I don't like this
one, even though it
does, in a sense,
what I'm looking for.
Because it kind of cheats.
When it has this, this refers
to the entire sentence itself.
It's using kind of
implicitly here a construct
which a Turing
machine does not have.
The Turing machine
does not have a way
of accessing its own code.
And in fact, really what the
point of this whole theorem
that we're going
to present is, is
that you don't need to have this
self-reference as a primitive.
You can get that effectively
using the procedure
that I'm describing, which
will give you the same effect.
So you don't need
it as a primitive.
You can design some
software basically,
which will give you
the same effect.
So let me show you how
to do that in English.
So let's look at
a slightly more--
whoops, cheating,
so Turing machines
don't have this
self-reference primitive.
So let's look at
another sentence here.
Write the following
twice, the second time
in quotes, and
then, "Hello World."
So what do we get if we
follow that instruction?
Well, you get "Hello World"
and then "Hello World"
again, now in quotes.
OK?
Hopefully not too bad.
But now, I'm one
step away for doing
the implementation of the
self-reproducing algorithm
in English.
Write the following twice,
the second time in quotes,
and then in quotes,
the same text.
Now following
those instructions,
you get, well, "Write
the following twice,
the second time in quotes,"
so that comes out here.
And the second time,
you put it in quotes,
just like you did with
the "Hello World."
But that's exactly
here, the output
is exactly what the input was.
And even though there is a
part of the sentence here
which refers to
a different part,
so here the first part is
referring to the second part,
never do I have to have
the sentence referring
to its entirety.
There's no part of
the sentence here
that's pointing at
the entire sentence.
And so, this here
manages to get the effect
that I'm looking for, where the
output is equal to the code,
but avoids having
the self-reference.
One thing is referring
to something else,
but not referring
back to itself.
So let me just see here.
So here, I'm going to have a
check-in on this in a minute.
So I'm going to try to
contrast what's happening here
with what's happening in
that Turing machine SELF
that I had from
the previous slide.
So why don't you mull this
over, and I'm going to give you
a check-in to see--
this is a little bit of
a challenging check-in.
But let's see if you can
figure your way through it.
And basically it says, so
really what we're doing here
is called the recursion
theorem, as you'll see.
We'll actually present the
recursion theorem formally
on the next slide.
But here, in both
of these cases,
we kind of have a template
part and an action part.
In both cases, there are two
parts to the instructions,
the template and the action.
OK?
So I'm going to leave
it to you to try
to imagine which
of those is which,
in each of these two examples.
And then, I'm going
to ask you to pick.
In the Turing machine, which
is the action and which
is the template,
and in the sentence,
which is the action and
which is the template.
The action is the
part where there's
some interesting sort of
instructional stuff happening
that you have to carry out.
The template is really basically
just text or just a string.
So let me pull up that poll.
See what you think.
Because I'm asking you
now to indicate where
is the action part in
both of those cases.
What is the upper
phrase and lower phrase?
I mean, of this sentence here.
So write the following twice.
This is the upper phrase.
And the part in quotations
is the lower phrase-- sorry.
OK, almost done here?
5 seconds-- a few of you
have not answered yet.
Answer it.
One second to go.
OK, here we go, ending polling.
So the majority here is correct.
I would say, in the
English sentence here,
the action part
is the first part.
That's where you actually have
been directed to do something.
The second half of the sentence,
the lower part of the sentence,
is just a template written.
This is just some string here.
There's no action
really being directed.
It happens to be
the same as the top,
but this could have
been just Hello World.
This could have been anything.
And then the upper
part acts on that.
So the upper part
is the action part.
So it's the upper phrase
that's the relevant part.
Now, in the Turing
machine, in a sense,
it's the other way around.
The first part is really
just the template.
The second part, B, is where
you're doing some actual work
on the template.
You're taking that, basically
text, which could be anything.
A could be anything.
And you're looking
at that template
and reconstructing what A
was from that string that
appears on the tape.
So B is actually the one
that's doing the work.
So it's B and the upper
phrase with part c is correct.
So let us continue then.
Oh, I want to mention here
problem 6 on the Pset.
So your job really is
to implement this in--
if you have a programming
language that you like--
it could be Python or whatever
your favorite Java, whatever
you like-- you can
implement this.
If you don't know any
programming languages,
then just make up some sort
of pseudo programming language
and implement it there.
Let me point out that
getting the quoting right
is a bit of a pain because
you have to kind of escape
the quotes and so on.
I'm not going to be
fussy about that.
So you can still get full
credit even if you don't get
the quoting part quite correct.
Do your best.
I think it's an interesting
problem to try to solve.
And if you struggle with it
for a while, it's slippery.
It's the kind of
thing you can easily
spend a couple of
hours on this problem.
Because it's a bit
tricky to manage
to make a program which
prints itself out,
which is what the task of
problem is on the Pset.
But don't fuss about
too much on the quoting
if that's the only thing
that's hanging you up.
Try to get the main structure
of it, which is fairly simple,
actually.
And if you can't get the
quoting part to work,
I'll ask the graders not to
penalize you for that part.
Let's look at the sort of
the more formal version
of what we've just done and
really kind of also taking it
to the next level.
Because being able to print
out a copy of yourself
is kind of a curiosity in a way.
But the recursion theorem
says, not only can you
make a machine which prints
out a copy of itself,
but you can actually
make a machine which
can obtain a copy of itself
and then do some computation
on that copy of itself, on its
own description, which actually
turns out to be a
useful thing to do.
Once you have access to
your own description,
as you'll see from
some examples,
then you can do perhaps some
interesting things with that.
So basically, what the
recursion theorem is,
is a kind of a compiler.
It allows you to have a
new primitive when you're
writing Turing
machines, which is,
compute your own description.
And the recursion theorem
will implement that for you.
OK?
So the technical form
of the recursion theorem
is going to look a little bit
counterintuitive, perhaps.
Let me put it out there.
If you struggle a little bit
with the slide, don't sweat it.
The main thing to remember,
and we'll see from examples,
is that you can compute your
own description in a Turing
machine.
And that's going to
be allowed as code.
So the way we're
going to do this
is, what the
recursion theorem does
for you is, it says you can
write a piece of code here.
Let's call it a piece
of Turing machine code--
algorithmic code--
called T. And T is
going to get transformed
into a new machine, R.
And R is going to get
provided a copy of the program
itself, which is just a
description of R, for free.
But otherwise, it's going
to act exactly like T.
So R is going to
act exactly like T,
except R is going to have
provided a copy of R.
And that's what the theorem
shows you how to implement.
So let me just see.
So for any machine, T,
there is a machine R
which, for any w, which is going
to be the input for R. R, on w,
operates the same as
R on the input with w
where it's given R. So R is
going to be getting access
to R without--
it's going to be obtaining
R by calculating it.
Maybe it'll be clear
from the proof.
I always struggled with how
to explain this clearly.
So now, the proof
of this is going
to be very much like
the proof from two
slides back, except it's
going to be three parts.
This is the part, T, that
you're going to provide.
And the T is going to be
the Turing machine code that
says, get your own description.
And you don't have to worry
about how that happens.
The compiler is going to add
on the A and B parts, which
is going to get the whole
description of the whole thing,
which is R, and feed it into
T as if T had it as an input.
So T is going to be allowed
to get its own description now
and operate on-- now does
its thing on the input w.
So the way it's going
to work, so T is given.
A is going to be, as before,
the description of B now with T.
So when A is done, it's going to
produce BT sitting on the tape
next to the w.
B is going to now figure out
what A was from the BT sitting
on the tape.
And then, it's going to combine
that to get ABT, which is R.
And after that, it passes
control to T with w and now R
sitting on the tape.
And now, T is going to
have its own description.
But don't forget, now T
has been modified to be R.
So it's not that T is
going to get T on the tape.
For this to make
sense, this is going
to be now the new machine R.
And R appears on the tape.
And now, the code
that you provided,
T, is now going to get
to operate on that.
OK?
If you didn't get that,
I'm not so worried.
The main thing is
that you can use
compute your own
description when you're
describing Turing machines.
That's what this
thing is telling you.
I think it'll be--
oh, there's a check-in here.
Yeah, so I don't know.
Let's do this one
kind of quickly here.
Can we use the recursion theorem
to design a machine T which,
instead of producing
its own description,
accepts only its own
description as an input?
So the language
of this machine is
going to be simply the one
string, the description of T.
So can we make a machine,
T, which does this?
Now I'm looking
at this check-in.
This T here is
confusing with that T.
It's not the same T. That's bad.
I should call it M. Design
a machine, M, where L of M
is the description of M.
And can we use the recursion
theorem to do that?
What I would ask you to do is
think about it in this context.
You can use compute
your own description
when you're writing the
code for this machine.
If you could do that,
could you make a machine
which just accepts
strings which happen
to be their own description?
This is supposed to be easy.
But I think it ended up being
a little bit more complicated
than I wanted.
Launch polling, make
your best guess.
I think you all kind of see--
I was kind of leading you,
leading you along the path
here.
Yes so, I think you're pretty
much all are getting it.
Maybe a few of you are unsure.
But anyway, let's just
wrap this one up quickly
so that we can move on.
I think you're pretty much-- so,
5 seconds, I'm going to end it.
So the correct answer is
Yes, as I was hinting at.
So I think maybe this example
would have been better
after the next example.
And then we're going
to have a break.
So here is a new proof
that ATM is undecidable
but now using the
recursion theorem.
And this is going to give
you a nice example of how
we use the recursion
theorem in action.
So remember, we spent half a
lecture or more with a proof
by diagonalization.
As our first example of an
undecidable problem ATM,
we subsequently
showed other things
undecidable by reduction.
But for the very first example,
we used that diagonalization.
Now I'm going to
give you a new proof.
So proof by
contradiction, assume
we have a Turing machine,
H, that decides ATM.
It starts the same way that
the diagonalization proof went.
But now I'm going to
make a new machine called
R. So this is going to be
different from the earlier
proof.
R says, on input w, I
get my own description.
Use the recursion theorem.
That's the way these
things always start.
Now, I'm going to use H. Now
that I know my own description,
I'm going to feed--
I can ask H. I can feed R, w--
w was the input here.
I can feed R, w into H to
determine whether R accepts w.
That's what H does.
Solving ATM, H will tell this
machine whether R accepts w.
R is the machine we're
writing, however.
That is the machine
that's currently running.
So R now uses H, and it knows
what it's supposed to do.
H is going to say, well,
you're going to accept w
or you're not going to accept w.
That's what H is assumed
to be able to do.
But then what is R
going to do after that?
R is going to do the opposite
of what H says it's going to do.
So if H says, R accepts w,
then R is going to reject w.
If H says R doesn't accept w--
it rejects it by looping or
halting, doesn't matter--
H just says it rejects, then
it's just going to accept.
So whatever H says, R is
going to show that H is wrong.
So that's a contradiction.
It says that H cannot
be deciding ATM.
So if you step back and think
about what this is here,
that's that whole
diagonalization proof
in one line.
Basically, we've done that
proof in a different way,
though there is some
similarity here.
I don't want to say that we've
totally reinvented things
and done that
totally differently.
But it's kind of, in
some ways, sort of
gets at the essence
of the diagonalization
in a certain sense.
But anyway, it gives you kind
of a new, very short proof
that ATM is undecidable.
I think that's kind
of a cool thing.
So why don't we take our
little coffee break here,
and you can feel free to ask
questions during the break.
I will start my timer going.
And we'll be back continuing
lecture in five minutes.
OK, so questions-- so we're
getting some questions
on when I said, we don't have
to worry about the quotes
when we're solving
problem 6 on the Pset.
Somebody says, can we just say
print A, B, C, instead of print
quote, "A, B, C," and it will
print A, B, C. Yes, you can--
don't worry about the quotes.
I think it's kind of--
you'll see a challenge
if you want to try
to get the quotes to work.
But it's also kind of a pain.
So yeah, you can just
kind of ignore the quotes,
and I'll ask the graders to
give that full marks there.
So any reasonable
interpretation will--
as long as you get the
rest of the concept right--
will be fine.
Let's see, somebody is asking,
In the recursion theorem,
why doesn't T get
the description of T
instead of the description of R?
Because the machine
that's running
is R, back in the previous
slide, two slides ago.
So if R got T, it would not be
getting its own description.
It would be getting
the description
of some other machine.
So you need to think
about what we actually
need to have happen here in the
proof of the recursion theorem.
But it needs to have R, not T.
Let's just see if I can--
why does R do the
opposite of what H says?
Why does R do the
Well, first of all,
I'm the one who
gets to design R. So
here is the code arc.
We're assuming we
have H. I'm going
to design R to do anything
I want to satisfy the proof.
And R here is designed
to do the opposite of H.
So I'm asking R--
I'm programming R
to find out what
H predicts it will do
and then do the opposite.
Maybe the situation
is sort of like this.
Suppose somebody says, I
have a crystal ball, which
is going to be like the role
of H. And you say, oh, really?
That's kind of cool.
I don't believe you, but it
still sounds interesting.
And the person says, yeah,
I can see the future.
I know what you're going
to do in five minutes.
And in fact, I can see
that in five minutes,
you're going to say, Hello.
And you can say, well,
you can think to yourself,
well, this person is nuts.
I'm not going to do that.
I'm just not going to say Hello.
And then the genie there
with the crystal ball
waits five minutes and
you don't say Hello.
And then you've proven that
the crystal ball doesn't work.
It's very similar.
I'm not going to explain how we
can do the combining in SELF.
I just want to explain
at a high level.
That's just going to be messy.
Because I said, we were somehow
going to combine in SELF.
Let me leave that as
a conceptual level.
OK, how does this idea
work for Turing machines?
I don't really
understand that question.
How does this idea work for
Turing machines are decidable?
You'll have to
resend that because I
don't understand the question.
Can I explain, use
your own description?
So when you write code that
says, get your own description,
after that code executes,
the Turing machine
appears on the tape, like
magic, the description
of its own code.
Say, sitting next to the
input to the machine,
because the machine may have
an separate input from that.
So the machine just
magically gets its own code.
And the proof of the recursion
theorem implements that,
so it's not magic after all.
But I still don't
understand the question.
So for problem 6, is it
enough to attach code?
If you're going to attach
code for problem 6, and that's
good enough.
Or if you can explain,
it's also good, like usual.
Do we worry about
tabs and new lines?
No.
OK, we're going to have to
defer the rest of the questions.
Don't forget we have
a zillion questions
here which I didn't get to.
OK, last one here-- why
does programming R do
the opposite of H?
Is that a contradiction?
Well, H is predicting that R
accepts, but R doesn't accept,
so H is wrong.
We're a little short on time.
Let me skip this one.
You can look at
this on your own.
I mean, this is proving
sort of the cool fact that--
I'll just say it
at a high level.
If you have a program
transformation,
so if I have some
method of transforming
one program to another program,
but it's done by algorithm.
So an algorithmic way
that transforms one
program to another program.
There's always going to be
some program whose behavior is
unchanged by the transformation.
That's called the
fixed point theorem.
So there some program
whose behavior
doesn't change no
matter how you try
two transform programs-- easy
proof using the recursion
theorem.
You can look at
the slide offline
separately if you like
to see how that goes.
It's pretty simple.
Here's another exercise
of the recursion theorem.
So if I have a--
let's say a Turing
machine is minimal
if its description is the
shortest among all Turing
machines which behave
the way it does,
which are equivalent to it.
When I was an undergraduate,
I took a programming class.
And some of us sort of
enjoyed writing short programs
to carry out the exercises.
Probably these days,
that's forbidden
because it just encourages
bad programming style.
But anyway, so you
kind of won if you
found the shortest solution for
a given programming exercise.
It was Heap Sort, I
remember, was one of the ones
that we had to do.
So this is sort of similar.
You might imagine if people try
to find the shortest possible
universal Turing machine.
So short is, in our
sense is, in terms
of whatever encoding
method we have in mind,
a machine is minimal if there
is no shorter program which
is equivalent using our
encoding system, whatever it is.
So M is minimal if anything
that has a shorter description
has a different language.
OK, so let's look at the
collection of all descriptions
of minimal Turing machines.
And I want to prove that that
language is unrecognizable.
I'm going to do it using
the recursion theorem.
And it's kind of
a cool exercise.
And you can actually use it to
prove something more powerful.
But let's focus on
this theorem for now.
So assume we have--
and it's also in the little
nice exercise about enumerators.
I don't know how comfortable
you ever got with enumerators.
But I'm trying to prove
this language here
is not recognizable.
And so remember,
enumerators, you
can enumerate exactly all
the recognizable languages.
So I'm going to assume I have
an enumerator for this language,
which just prints out all of
the minimal Turing machines.
So I have some enumerator.
It's a program that prints
out the descriptions of all
of the minimal--
the shortest possible
Turing machines.
And now I'm going to
get a contradiction.
So we're going to build
this Turing machine, R,
which gets its own description.
And then, it's going to
start the enumerator until--
so looking at the strings
that the enumerator produces.
So this enumerator is producing
these minimal Turing machines,
one after the next-- chunk,
chunk, chunk, chunk, chunk.
All these minimal Turing
machines are coming out.
And you keep looking at those
until you find one of them
which is bigger than yourself.
And how do you know how
big you are yourself?
From the description you're
given by the recursion theorem.
So you keep on printing
out these Turing machines
until you find one that's
bigger than yourself.
And then, what do
you do with that?
You simulate that.
So now, so what?
Well, the point is
that you're going
to be smaller than that
machine that you're simulating.
Because you waited
to find a machine
that the enumerator produced
which is bigger than you.
So you're going to be
simulating that machine that's
bigger than you.
And so, you're going to be doing
exactly what that machine does
on every input,
because you're always
going to be simulating that
same machine on every input.
And so, you're going to be
equivalent to that bigger
machine.
But that bigger machine
is supposed to be minimal
because E is producing it.
But here, you are
exhibiting a machine
that's smaller than that--
that allegedly minimal
machine couldn't be minimal.
That's the contradiction.
So the language of R, this
machine I just produced,
equals the language of B.
Because R ends up simulating B.
But R is smaller
than B because R
waited until it found a bigger
machine that's bigger than it.
So B couldn't be minimal,
but B was one of the machines
that the enumerator produced.
That's a contradiction.
So let me do a check-in on this.
I expect this is going to
cause some of you heartburn,
but let's do the best you can.
Suppose I have this collection
of minimal Turing machines
and I take some
infinite subset of that.
So now I'm not demanding
that I have all
of the minimal Turing machines.
I just have infinitely many
minimal Turing machines.
Is it possible that
subset-- whatever it is--
could be Turing-recognizable?
Now, think about that.
Now, you can have
languages which
are not
Turing-recognizable, that
have infinite
Turing-recognizable subsets.
Could that be for this language?
And maybe I'll give you a--
it will be helpful to you to
understand and perhaps apply
the methodology that I gave
you in this proof here.
And that might be
helpful to you.
But I can see this is not--
this one is a bit of a struggle.
OK, let's end it.
Two seconds, just
pick something.
So the majority has the
correct answer here.
So in fact, this
proof would still
work if the enumerator was
enumerating an infinite subset
of minimal Turing machines.
Because all you need
is to wait until one
that's bigger than you appears.
And all that R
needs to do is wait
until one that's
bigger than R appears,
which will certainly
happen eventually
if the subset is infinite.
And then R simulates that bigger
machine and acts the same way,
thereby proving it
could not be minimal.
So it's exactly the same proof
shows that the answer here
is No.
And it's a kind of a curiosity.
It's not necessarily
that easy to construct
languages which not only
are they not recognizable,
but they have no
recognizable subsets--
infinite subsets.
Obviously, a finite
subset is going
to be recognizable because it
would be decidable as well.
So anyway, let's move on.
Some other
applications-- so first,
a real-world application--
somebody is asking
for an example
of a language of a
recognizable subset
of a non-recognizable language.
So starting out with something
which is not recognizable,
and can we come
up with a quick--
So here is, I don't know
if this will help you.
So the question is,
can I give an example
of a non-recognizable language
that has a recognizable subset?
So I didn't prepare this, but
let me see if this helps you.
So let's take ATM complement.
We already showed that ATM
complement is not recognizable.
So these are the sets
of pairs, M and w,
where M does not accept w.
So if I focus only on those
M's, which are finite automata,
which are a subclass
of Turing machines,
then I can get the
answer for those M's.
So for the infinitely many cases
where the Turing machine never
writes on its tape, it
even becomes decidable.
So I don't know
if that's helpful,
but you can
definitely find cases
where there are
undecidable languages that
have decidable subsets,
unrecognizable languages that
have recognizable
infinite subsets.
But there's one example
where it's not true,
in the previous slide.
OK, a lot of questions
are coming up here.
Yes, I'm seeing some
other proposals here.
If you take ATM
complement and you union
with just any old
strings of 1's,
just one star, assuming
that one star--
just strings of
1's are never going
to code for a Turing machine--
that's still going
to be unrecognizable.
But then you can
just throw away all
of those just strings
of 1's, and you're
going to get an infinite subset.
Oh, wait a minute.
It's still unrecognizable.
That's no good.
Oh, no, yeah, I threw
away the wrong stuff.
You throw away the descriptions
of the Turing machines,
and you just have the
one-star strings left.
And so, that becomes
decidable, even regular.
Anyway, I'm not sure
I'm helping you.
Let's move on to
other applications.
So this is kind of a curious
application that actually
is in the real world,
where a machine might want
to get a copy of itself and
then do something perhaps
even nefarious with a
copy of its own code.
And that would be
a computer virus.
Computer viruses make
copies of themselves
and then propagate them through
the internet, or whatever media
you have, to infect
other computers.
And I'm sure we all
know computer viruses.
Well, they need to get
copies of themselves
in order to do the infection.
How do they do that?
Many of them operate in a way
where in either in a language
or in a system, where
they can make reference
to their own code, either by
looking at the machine code,
or whatever direct
access to their own code.
There are languages and
systems which allow for that.
But I'm not an expert
on computer viruses.
I would be shocked if they're
not some other viruses that
get access to their own code by
using something in the same--
using basically the method
of the recursion theorem.
I haven't done a
systematic study.
But I'm sure, if
you can't access
to your own code directly
using some operating system
mechanism, some primitive,
the only other way
is basically doing the method
that we just described.
OK, so another application
is in a branch of mathematics
called mathematical logic.
Where, I imagine that many
of you have heard of the work
of Godel from the earlier
part of the 20th century,
where they show that
you can come up--
it's possible to demonstrate
that there are true
mathematical statements but
which cannot be proven to be
true.
So proof-- there might be
something like maybe even
questions of interest to us,
like P versus NP question,
which we will, at some point,
look at in a few weeks--
actually, yeah, maybe two
or three weeks from now.
There are many unsolved
mathematical problems.
And people wonder,
maybe there's just
no way to prove them
one way or the other.
So in the 1930s, when
Godel did his work,
he shocked the
mathematical community
by showing that proof does
not work for everything.
There may be things that are
true that you cannot prove.
In Hilbert, in particular,
from Hilbert's 10th problem,
he was dismayed by this
result. Because he had earlier
believed that anything that
was true you could prove.
So anyway, let's just see how--
I'm going to sketch how we
actually go about doing that.
Because we now have a
kind of enough technique
to at least give you
an idea of how do
you demonstrate that there are
true but unprovable statements
and actually even exhibit one.
OK, mathematical logic
is the mathematical study
of mathematics itself.
Godel's first incompleteness
theorem, as we described,
is that in any
reasonable formal system
of mathematical
provability, there
are going to be some
true statements that
are not provable.
And in order to sort of get
the sketch of the proof--
I shouldn't say proof here.
We're going to proof sketch.
We're going to basically use
two properties of formal proof
systems.
One is that kind of obvious
property that you would expect
all probability systems to
have, is that you can only
prove true things.
So if something is being
proven, it's going to be true.
You can't prove anything false.
If you can prove false things,
your system of provability
is bad.
And the other thing
is that proofs
are checkable by machine.
So if you write down-- do
your system in a formal way
and you have this
formal notion of proofs,
which underlies all mathematical
reasoning, by the way.
This is completely
well accepted.
Both of these properties are
accepted by mathematicians.
Then in principle, you can
convert any mathematical proof
into a form that you can
check it by computer.
It might become much longer.
But in principle, you can
put the proof into a form
where a computer
could check the proof.
And the way we're going
to frame that in the way
we've been talking
about things is
that the language of
all pairs of proof,
comma statement being proved--
so where pi is a proof
of the statement phi--
that's a decidable thing.
So you can check, by
machine, whether pi
is a valid proof of phi.
So your proof checker can say,
Yes, it's valid, No, not valid.
And that's something
you can do by algorithm.
So those are the two
assumptions that we're
going to make about
our system of proofs.
And that's all
we're going to need.
Now, the first
conclusion, which is,
I think, a good sort of
a little bit of exercise
on the kind of thinking we've
been doing in this course.
Number 2, checkability
implies that the set
of provable statements
is recognizable.
Why?
Suppose I give you a
statement that has a proof--
a provable statement.
I'm not saying it's a true
statement, necessarily.
That's going to be perhaps a
larger class of statements.
But the statement
that do have proofs,
that's a recognizable language.
Because, if I give
you a statement,
your recognizer is going
to take that statement
and start looking through
all possible proofs.
It's going to look at string
after string as a candidate
proof, one after the next.
Some strings, of course-- most
strings are going to be junk.
But every once in a while, a
proof is going to come out.
It's going to be a string which
is a valid proof of something.
And then you're
going to check, oh,
let me just see if
that's a valid proof.
And if it does prove the
statement that I have in mind,
and if it is, then I
accept that statement.
And it goes through
statement by--
the input is a
mathematical statement.
And that's going to be accepted
if the machine, by looking
through all possible
proofs, finds one
and then it accepts
that statement.
So the collection
of all statements
that have a proof,
that's recognizable.
So similarly, if you take
statements of the form
M and w is in the
complement of ATM.
So M doesn't accept w.
If you take all statements
of that form where M doesn't
accept w, or M, w is in
the complement of ATM,
some of those statements may
have proofs in your system.
Some of them may
not have proofs.
If all of them
had proofs, if you
can prove every
statement of this form
when it happens to be true--
obviously, you can't prove
the ones that are not true.
But if you can prove all the
true statements of this kind,
then ATM complement would
be Turing-recognizable.
Because you can go through, just
for the same reason as above.
But we know that that's false.
So there must be some
statement of this kind which is
true but does not have a proof.
Because otherwise,
the ATM complement
would be recognizable.
So we've actually done the first
half of Godel's incompleteness
theorem.
The second half, which
we're going to unfortunately
not have time to finish, but let
me just give you the outline,
is that we can use the recursion
theorem to give it specific--
see, what we showed
here is that there
is some statement of this form
which is true but unprovable.
It doesn't exhibit
a particular one.
Now the recursion theorem allows
you to give a particular one.
And the one, it
basically implements
Godel's so-called Godel
statement or Godel
sense that says, "This
statement is unprovable."
And you can formalize
that precisely.
And then that statement
becomes true but unprovable.
Let's just say why that is.
Because if the
statement were false,
suppose the
then, well, then it
would be provable.
Because the truth says
it's not provable.
But if the statement
were provable,
then it had to be
true, which would
mean it would be unprovable.
So the only viable outcome
here is that the statement
is unprovable.
And which is, it's
therefore that it's true
that it's unprovable.
So that this is
a true statement,
but then it has no proof.
And let me not go through
it because again, we're
unfortunately running
short on time.
But you can implement this using
the recursion theorem to make
a particular machine, R, where
you cannot prove that R does
not accept, say, some string 0.
So you can find a particular
R using the recursion
theorem, where it's
impossible to prove
that R doesn't accept 0.
Even though, by construction,
R does not accept 0.
So it's a little
bit slippery there
because you have
to understand what
we mean by proof within
the formal system
versus our external
form of reasoning,
but taking us a
little bit far afield.
So for those of you who care,
I hope this little digression
was interesting.
As I mentioned at the
beginning, for those
of you who don't care, you
don't have to worry about it.
It's not going to be on the
midterm or on the final exam.
You're not going to be
responsible for this last five
minutes or so of the lecture.
But I thought it's kind of
an interesting application
of the recursion theorem to
a problem outside of computer
science in mathematical logic.
OK, so here is the entire
reasoning here again.
I invite you to look
at that on the slide
that I posted if you're curious.
So anyway, a quick
review of today
is, we went through
self-reference
and the recursion theorem.
We gave a few applications.
And we did a sketch of Godel's
first incompleteness theorem
in mathematical logic.
OK, so that's all I'm going
to have for you today.
We're out of time.
And I will take any questions.
So getting back to the MIN
Turing machine example,
somebody is asking,
how do I know
there's a Turing machine that's
longer than the machine, R,
that I'm building?
Well, there are infinitely
many machines in MIN TM
or in the infinite
subset of MIN TM.
So eventually, one
of them is going
to have to be longer than the
machine that I'm constructing.
Because that's a machine
of some very specific size,
and so eventually there's going
to have to be one that's bigger
that shows up.
So this may be a
similar question.
Now, another similar question
is about, how big is R?
And does the size of R in
that previous thing here--
I don't know if we want
to go through this.
But, OK, let's
quickly look at it.
This machine, R, has a
fixed, predetermined size.
Its size does not depend on B.
It depends on E because it's
going to be simulating E.
But E might be producing
very, very long strings.
Eventually, it will.
So E is fixed.
And then, R's size is fixed.
So eventually, R
will find a machine
that's bigger than it is.
But let's look at--
right, so this is
a good question.
I was wondering if I would
get questions of this kind.
This is getting back to
the question in logic
here at the end.
Yes, because I said this
statement here is unprovable.
But in a sense, I proved it.
Because how do I know it's true?
And I gave you an
argument for it.
And so, you have
to differentiate
between the reasoning
that we're providing
and the formal system that
we're reasoning about.
And the formal system
that we're reasoning about
is not capable of proving this.
But we're outside
that formal system
so that we can reason
about the formal system.
I know it's a little
bit perverse seeming.
And mathematical logic
is a little tricky
because it has to deal
with those kinds of issues.
But this is arguing within
any particular formal system
of probability, this
is going to be true.
But that's kind of
an approximation
to our own thought process.
So it's slippery, I agree.
So, a good question here,
would Godel's theorem still
hold informal systems where
we don't require that proofs
of statements are decidable?
So I'm not saying that
the proofs are decidable.
That you can--
proofs are checkable.
So you can test whether
a proof is a proof.
If you can't test whether
a proof is a proof,
I don't know of any people who
have studied that situation.
So that's a little bit
of a trickier case.
I'm not sure what
to say about that.
Can I give an example of two
equivalent Turing machines
where one has a shorter
description than the other?
How do we define the
length of the description?
Well, we never really precisely
defined our encoding system.
But whatever encoding
system you want to use,
is going to represent
Turing machines as strings.
And those strings are
going to have a length.
And so, it doesn't
really matter which
encoding system you're going to
use because the statement isn't
going to be true in any of them.
We could go through the
exercise of defining
a particular encoding system.
It's going to be pretty
tedious to do that.
But you can just imagine writing
down the states, the transition
function, et cetera, et cetera,
as this big long string.
And that's going to be
our encoding system.
And then there are going
to be some long machines.
Some machines will have
long representations
and other machines that
have short representations.
And there's going to
be some machine where
you can introduce a
bunch of useless states
that are never accessed.
So you can expand--
you can kind of add
junk to the description
of the machine, which is
not going to do anything.
But it's just going to make
the description of the machine
unnecessarily long
compared to what
with some other
description, which
is going to compute the same
thing but will be much shorter.
So you can certainly
find examples
of pairs of machines that
do the same thing where one
is much longer than the other.
So I will then close
the session here.
And I will be very shortly
on the office hours link
and see some of you there.